there is risks to you choosing to be a  leader  there is risks there's risks to you  showing that you're a true leader  there is a very risk to you being a  tough father there is risks to you being  a high expectation type of a dad there's  risks to you being a guy that expects a  lot from people there's my kids are  going to baseball my son is going to  baseball practice right now  and this place is going i'm standing on  the sidelines just watching to see how  these guys coach the kids  and i see hey you don't come out here  you don't do this run two laps hey bone  five push-ups hey you dropped the ball  five push-ups hey you don't do this go  run over here at the end of the two-hour  practice these guys are sweating you  know what i said on the sidelines he's  in the right place these are real  coaches coaching these guys they're  tough no listen at the end of the day  i don't care about optics i want a  leader today america is desperately  looking for leader